hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man far
from home dazzles us with insane imagery
in details with pretty much every shot
covered with interesting clues to find
and also pretty much every shot probably
lying to us about whether it's real or a
Mysterio illusion yeah I don't think
I'll ever be able to drive through fog
again there's just so much in this movie
that the filmmakers actually had to
remove some even crazier scenes and
imagery that would have made far from
home a very different movie including a
pretty cool alternate version of
Mysterio's illusion montage I'm gonna
explain what you missed it spoiler
warning in case you don't want to know
okay first part from home doesn't waste
much time before sitting Peter Parker
and his classmates off to Europe but
originally the first act of this movie
had a lot more action with spider-man in
New York a lot of this deleted footage
actually appeared in marketing for the
film I'd seen in trailers there was
going to be a montage of Peters to-do
lists before he left including returning
to Del Mar's deli from spider-man
homecoming getting his passport which
might have led to some interesting
confusion since Peter would be 5 years
older at least on paper than he should
be thanks to the blip there's also going
to be a scene in which Peter sold his
Star Wars toys in order to buy a present
for MJ but he was unable to part ways
with this Lobot figurine actually went
into that one in another video but most
critically from this to-do list Peter
was going to use his iron spider suit to
take down a major crime syndicate which
a deleted clip of an may hints that from
a trailer take down the moon Freddie mom
so in the spider-man comics leadman
Freddy's are the crime gang of Silvio
Manfredi aka the villain Silvermane who
might have been connected to the
elaborately dressed figure that
Spiderman has webbed up hanging from
behind the chandelier he or she appears
to be wearing a leopard print outfit
leading me originally to speculate that
this could be a version of Kraven the
hunter but either way it appears that
originally this first act was going to
show spider-man making more and more
enemies locally in New York before
leaving for Europe add the man Freddy's
to Adrian Toomes and Mac Gargan still
plotting revenge against Peter from that
homecoming post-credit scene and perhaps
far from home was gonna set the stage
for a long list of villains waiting for
Peter back home these villains could get
mobilized by Jay jonah jameson into a
collective kind of like the sinister six
all taking that more in
episode coming soon the director of this
movie John Watts has said that this
first act montage will appear as a short
film for the movies blu-ray release
later this year but that brings us to my
favorite sequence afar from home the
Mysterio illusion montage which was
already packed with insanely trippy
imagery from a zombie Iron Man 2
spider-man trapped in a snow globe but
the film's visual effects supervisor
said that their main priority here was
to differentiate this sequence from dr.
Strange's multiverse magical mystery
tour and that crafting the montage was
one of the most complicated processes of
the production and that lots of
alternate surreal imagery had to be
removed this included a fight in which
the Cape of Mysterio creates a monster
that attacks spider-man who would be
running on a giant chessboard and later
on giant piano keys he said that there
was also a deleted shot of masks of
various sizes and a giant spider in a
spiderweb
attacking Peter and that this got to be
75% completed before it was dropped and
thank God because that [ __ ] would have
redirected my eyes to the floor and made
me miss every easter egg left in the
film if only all spiders could be just
illusions the VFX supervisor also
pointed out one cool Easter egg that
actually stayed in though the camera
movement makes it really hard to see I
did catch part of it my full movie
breakdown go check that out but at one
point you can see spider-man standing on
a stone base of Captain America shield
and apparently surrounding him are
statues of all of the fallen superheroes
from Avengers end game including Iron
Man Black Widow vision and cap and have
caps not technically fallen though he's
not in their world anymore so they kind
of knew him as fallen so if you look
beside that giant shield there's
actually cat's face and I'm pretty sure
that was caps fist that crushes down on
top of Peter and you'll notice that the
only statute left standing is that of
Mysterio representing how in Mysterio's
eyes in the ashes of Tony Stark and the
rest Mysterio is now the world's new
Avenger to rise not spider-man
and speaking of post endgame Avengers
the writers did reveal that they also
wanted to try to work in a cameo by the
new Captain America Sam Wilson though
the director said that that idea was
just a rumor was never fully developed
Watts also said they consider trying to
work in an Easter Egg to Captain Britain
the group of alternate reality Avengers
led by a British version of cap this
group also included a Britta
version of spider-man aka spider UK
Billy Braddock we didn't get kind of
close to a reference to him though the
fake alternate dimension that Mysterio
claimed to be from Earth 833 which in a
Comics Marvel multiverse is the home
universe of spider UK and finally we did
also learn about an alternate ending to
far from home
see instead of being outed in framed by
Mysterio and Jay jonah Jameson in a
post-credits scene originally Spiderman
was going to voluntarily sacrifice his
identity publicly during the final
battle with Mysterio in London but I
want to dig into this alternate ending a
bit more in another video that'll be
coming out soon now I do have more far
from home breakdowns in the works I'm
not talking about what directions the
third movie of this trilogy could go
with Peter Parker now exposed by Jay
jonah Jameson and possible appearances
by the sinister six or venom as well as
Mysterio's secret plan here like how his
illusions worked exactly and how deep
they went and soon Marvel Studios will
return to Hall H of Comic Con where
Kevin bayou makers will cameo and give
us ton of details about the future of
the MCU this is gonna be so much to talk
about I don't want to drive myself crazy
trying to tackle all of it alone again
this year so hopefully I get some new
friends to come in and help out but
which of these deleted scenes would you
have preferred to have stayed in the
film comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on instagram and
twitter at a boss and subscribe to new
rockstars to break down two theories
about everything Marvel thank you for
joining me and recently I assume the
spider was just a false projection by
Mysterio and now it laid eggs in my
brain
[Music]